un drama familiar iraní y una cinta
francesa filmada en américa central
pasaron frente a los ojos del jurado en
cannes
el joven prodigio del cine iraní saeed
hasta allí entró por la puerta grande
del festival de cannes con su primer
largometraje ley las brothers una cinta
seleccionada en la competencia esta
tragicomedia cuenta la historia de leila
y sus hermanos quienes sortean la
miseria y el desempleo regla decida
entonces abrir un negocio familiar sin
ayuda financiera pero se entera luego de
que su padre va a destinar una gran suma
de dinero a convertirse en el padrino de
su comunidad lo que desencadena una
lucha de estrategias que va a llevar a
la familia al borde del precipicio ley
las brothers impresionó a la crítica y
se ha convertido en una seria candidata
a la palma de oro en cannes
de su lado la francesa claire denis
cuenta la huida de nicaragua de dos
amantes ella es una periodista
alcohólica que se prostituye para
recuperar su pasaporte y un poco de
dinero el un hombre de negocios
implicado en un tráfico de influencias
clear then y la lleva a la actualidad en
medio de la pandemia la corrupción y la
represión del régimen de daniel ortega
[Música]
pero la cinta que monopolizó todas las
miradas fue elvis la superproducción de
baz luhrmann sobre el rey del rock and
roll una cinta llena de música
protagonizada por el joven y hasta ahora
desconocido osten butler y el veterano
tom hanks
[Aplausos]
[Música]